if you're a gmail user and you want to
get more from the program I'm going to
share with you today my seven power tips
to massively produce your productivity
from Gmail hi I'm Evan Carmichael
welcome to another technology Tuesday
I'm a huge gmail user and I'm going to
share with you the seven ways that I use
it to boost my productivity so I'm going
to load up my gmail so you can follow
along with me as I explain the tips
number one is rapportive and rapportive
is a cool way for you to be able to find
out a little bit of information on who
the people are that you're talking with
so you can learn about them after port
of comm and what it does is instead of
showing you the ads on the side of
Google it shows you information about
the person that you're connected to so
if I load up an email I got this one
from Ricardo you'll see on the side
it'll show Ricardo it'll show his
picture to show his email it'll show his
LinkedIn it shows that we're connected
it shows me his Twitter it shows me I
can add into my circle his skype he
commented on one of my videos it shows
me a lot of information about him at a
quick glance instead of seeing the ads
so super helpful especially when you're
dealing with people who you have no idea
who they are and they're emailing you my
second power tip is use the tabs so if
you're back on your inbox you may have
noticed a Gmail added a whole bunch of
different tabs to the top for the most
part I deleted all of them and just kept
one I chose forums where you can keep
whichever one that you want and why I
kept it here is to have two major
inboxes one where everything goes and in
the tab the forum's tab I put all my
important emails so these are the ones
from my family here's my dad from people
on my team from key suppliers from media
from big customers and I do this so that
when I check my email in the morning I
only checked my forums tab I just check
it here to see what important emails
have come in from the VIPs in my life
that I need to get back to you can also
set it on your Gmail app for your phone
or for your tablet to look only at that
tab so it's an easy way to sort through
your emails if I wanted to add somebody
in so here's a Google+ Hangout say I
wanted to always have that go to forms I
could drag it in and then there's this
little rule here do this for future
messages I always click yes so any new
Google
hangout will automatically appear in
here as well so here's the one and any
future ones will automatically appear
here as well so that's how I created
these custom rules to have the VIPs go
to my forums tab power tip number three
is use boomerang if you've ever found
that you wanted to send an email but not
have it send out right away you wanted
to send it tomorrow or the next week as
a reminder or you just didn't want to
hear back from that person too soon so
you want to delay the email going out
you can use boomerang so if I click on
an email here back to Ricardo I could do
a reply and then with boomerang
installed you can send later so I could
say Thank You Ricardo and I could click
send later and then pick a time where I
want this message to go out it could be
an hour two hours four hours tomorrow
afternoon tomorrow morning a week a
month a specific time you can make it
recurring so that it sends every week if
you want it to so if you want to nag
somebody here remind them or remind
yourself you can set a recording message
the other thing that lets you do is it
will return the message to you as an
option if you haven't heard back from
that person so if you're using Gmail as
a sales tool or you want to make sure
that people are reading what you're
writing then you can see boomerang this
in two days it'll load this up so that
logs me into my boomerang account and
then basically if I send this email to
Ricardo and he doesn't respond to me
within whatever time set I want to put
in then it will send it back to my inbox
as a reminder that I need to get back in
touch with Ricardo to get this it's free
for a certain number of emails and you
just go to boomerang gmail comm my power
tip number four is use labels and
filters so labels are like folders if
you use two outlook labels are your
folders that appear down the side here
and what I use the filters for are
basically rules that help you figure out
which email should go to which labels
which folders and what I really like
using this for is if I get a lot of
emails that are built in certain topic
that I don't want to clog up my inbox
right I already have enough emails
coming in here that I don't want to be I
don't want to have it filled up here so
an example could be social media
notifications or sales of my
product so I need on the side here a
junkie is sales of my online products
that I could go in and see what the most
recent sales are oDesk are notifications
from Oh dad's that probably have been
billed or updates and notifications that
I need to get through and so I set
automatic rules that they skip my inbox
and then go to that specific folder so
that when I'm ready to look at them I
can just go in and look at them to
access it I need to move my screen over
a little bit so you guys can see you got
to go to the Settings button and at the
top there are labels and filters so
labels are all the different labels that
you want to create so there are some
that are automatically there and you can
decide if you want to show them or hide
them by default and then I've created
these so I have AM are a junkie fiber
Gretchen Monday social authors any Weber
I've got a lot of labels for a lot of
different things and then if you go to
the filters and lets you set up the
rules so I can find the e junkie one as
an example so here anything that comes
from notifications at a junkie comm I
apply the label eat junk e and have it
skip the inbox so it does it fill out my
inbox that it goes automatic to the
folder and I can check it out whenever I
want so super helpful time-saving and
helps keep things organized
my power tip number five is use
forwarding and forwarding allows you to
send emails of a certain kind you set up
a rule that then it's forwarded to
somebody else or to a different email
address so if there's something that you
are always sending to somebody on your
team that you want them to always see
instead of having to manually do it it
can automatically go to them first to do
it you have to set up forwarding so you
go to the forwarding tab at the top this
is again under the the settings and you
have to be approved to be able to
forward messages so these are a few the
people on my team that I've set up so
that I can send emails to them and it'll
send them a notification to say hey Evan
wants to be able to forward emails to
you yes or no and they approve then once
they've approved you can go to the
filters and you can find different
forwards on so you create a rule to say
you know this comes from whatever email
address it automatically gets forwarded
to this person so here's something
that's going
this is a media releases that I get goes
to Mansoor who is on my team and is in
charge of finding opportunities it also
goes to a DS and Justin R which test one
these were marketing tests that I got
and this would forward to Maria who was
doing marketing for me and so any emails
that are coming in regularly that you
know you just want to forward to
somebody else you can set that up so it
happens automatically my number six tip
is auto advance this is a minor trick
but one that saves me a lot of time and
having to click so if I look at an email
and I see Ricardo and he wishes me happy
Easter I can write back to him and I say
thank you Ricardo
much appreciated after I send I'm going
to archive it and it'll auto advance to
the next email so if I go archived it
goes to my next email my box so normally
you'd have to click back or it'll send
you back here then I got to click on the
next one so it saves a click each time
and you know a small little trick but
one if you're just going through your
inbox makes it so much easier to get
there let me move this over again so we
can see you want to go to your settings
then click on labs and then one of them
will be called Auto advance so if you do
a search here for Auto advanced you will
find it and you just have to enable it
and it's free and super helpful and
saves you time in answering emails and
my number seven power tip is used canned
responses if you find yourself saying
the same thing to a lot of different
emails that are coming in is the same
response you can use a canned response
so that you don't have to always type in
the same thing over and over and over
again so sure how it works is pretty
quick you go compose email at the bottom
here next to the trash can use the down
arrow you can go to canned responses and
in here I've got three it's a coffee
meeting a salsa private a phone meeting
and if we're going to meet for coffee
I'll just put it here what I want to do
is send people link to my schedule so I
have a schedule that people can look at
and then book so I'll say here's link to
my schedule so we can plan a time right
so that I never remember what this link
is and so this saves me the time from
having to
you put that in so if you ever have to
remember a link or you just find
yourself having the same responses to
lots of different emails you can set up
a canned response and then automatically
include it with a few clicks instead of
having to type it out each time thank
you so much for watching my question for
you guys today is how are you using
Gmail I'd love to hear your tips your
productivity hacks leave it in the
comments below if you like this video
and you want to see more don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and to the
newsletter thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon